Hallo zusammen, ich bin wirklich froh,
äh die Firma util heute für unsere heutige Sitzung bei uns zu haben äh
heute werden wir mehr angewandte Fragen
äh in Bezug auf künstliche Intelligenz
diskutieren, nachdem wir
klassischere Ansätze für KI diskutiert hatten, angefangen
von Touring
uh bis Searle und
auch to  dryfoods heute möchten wir
diese Frage aus einer eher
angewandten Perspektive diskutieren und ich freue mich sehr
,
drei Leute von util hier bei uns zu haben
und
sie werden jetzt einige Informationen
über ihre Firma präsentieren, was ich tun wollte,
ist nur ein paar auszugeben  Minuten
mit zwei Dingen,
eines davon ist ein bisschen mein
Hintergrund
und teilweise auch der Hintergrund von
util und warum ein Unternehmen wie unseres KI verwendet und
warum das eine wichtige Sache in dem
Bereich ist, in dem wir uns befinden, also das erste
Die Sache ist die, dass ich eigentlich von einem früheren Unternehmen nach Utah gekommen bin
, das KI im
Finanzwesen und in der
Arbeit für die US-Regierung eingesetzt hat
Es gibt nicht genug menschliche
Analysten auf der Welt
,
um die großen Probleme der Datenanalyse anzugehen.
Wir hatten ein Projekt in meiner letzten Firma,
bei dem
sie das berechnet haben, um
die gleiche Arbeit zu leisten, die sie
mit KI geplant hatten  Sie müssten acht
Millionen menschliche Analysten einstellen und
könnten das einfach nicht ohne Technologie tun, die
ihnen hilft,
und das ist sehr genau das
Thema vieler KI-Arbeiten, die vor sich gehen.
Ich bin sicher, Sie haben darüber gesprochen
Wenn es um Nutzen geht, greifen wir ein
sehr ähnliches Problem an, aber wir
greifen auch eines an, das meines
Erachtens eine eher
globale Relevanz hat, nämlich dass wir
versuchen sicherzustellen, dass die
Investmentwelt die Informationen hat, die sie benötigt
Um diese Investitionen auf nachhaltige Ergebnisse auszurichten, haben
wir gesehen,
dass die Finanzmärkte im Allgemeinen
sehr gut funktionieren, wenn Sie
finanzielle Risiken verstehen wollen und wenn Sie
darin gut sind, können Sie Geld verdienen,
aber gleichzeitig gibt es jede Menge  Wenn
Unternehmen
, die auf dem Markt belohnt werden, aber
sehr unnachhaltige Praktiken haben, und was
wir gesehen haben, ist, dass Ölunternehmen
sehr gut abschneiden, wissen wir, dass
dies irgendwann enden muss, aber trotzdem
geht alles so weiter, wie es
normalerweise bei Energieunternehmen der Fall ist  sehr
ähnlich sind, äh, es gibt viele Unternehmen
, die in diese Kategorie fallen,
und doch, wenn ein Investor wirklich verstehen will,
wie mache ich eine Investition, die
besser für die Welt ist, als nur
eine Art gedankenlose,
äh, Zuteilung von Geld,
wie mache ich das?  in einem realistischen sinne
und wir standen vor genau dem gleichen problem wie
in meinem letzten job, nämlich dass
es zu viele informationen gibt, die zu
komplex sind, um dies zu verstehen,
und das eine, was ich hinzufügen würde, ist meiner meinung nach
wirklich
entscheidend  dass wir es mit einer Welt zu tun haben,
die nein ist und ich werde
zwischen zwei Wörtern unterscheiden, die sehr ähnlich klingen,
ähm,
die Welt war früher kompliziert und
das bedeutet, dass die Beziehung  Schiffe
zwischen Problemen sind linear,
also ist
es im Grunde eine Frage des Hinzufügens von
Dingen, und Sie wissen, je mehr Sie hinzufügen,
desto mehr müssen Sie auf der anderen Seite hinzufügen,
um dem entgegenzuwirken. Es ist einfach eine
perfekte Balance. Es gibt mehr Daten, Sie
brauchen mehr Analysten, Sie haben mehr  mehr Daten
braucht man mehr Analysten, und
das ist eine lineare Beziehung.
Früher war die Welt so, heute
ist sie nicht mehr so, sie ist jetzt
komplex, was bedeutet, dass mehrere
Datensätze gleichzeitig vorhanden sind und
ein Analyst nicht genug tun kann  und es
bedeutet, dass Sie, wenn Sie Daten hinzufügen,
die
Komplexität der verwendeten Daten tatsächlich exponentiell multiplizieren, und ein
Analyst
wird dies nicht auf lineare Weise erfüllen,
sodass das Diagramm
nicht mehr
in einer organisierten Weise abläuft  und das ist,
wo Sie wirklich
eine Technologie brauchen, die skalieren kann, um das zu
tun, also kommen wir ins
Spiel, und das ist wirklich der Hintergrund,
warum wir KI
verwenden, ist die Menge an Informationen
und  die komplexität dieser informationen
macht es unmöglich, auf
technologie zu verzichten, die uns hilft,
also übergebe ich sie in diesem sinne an raquel
, die sie durch das aussehen unseres produkts führen wird,
und dann wissen sie alle fragen
zur ai-seite der dinge  technische
Details und wie unsere Modelle für maschinelles Lernen funktionieren, können wir mit
Sicherheit ansprechen. Was ich Ihnen jetzt zeigen werde,
ist eine Demo dessen, wie unser Produkt aussieht
und was wir
unseren Kunden liefern. Was wir an unsere Kunden liefern,
sind im Grunde Daten  die
Umsatzausrichtung von Unternehmen und
die verschiedenen SDGs, also
das Beispiel, das ich durchgehen werde, ist Apple,
und dies kann wie
alle anderen Fragen beginnen, die Sie
haben, wie wir die Ergebnisse
zusammenstellen und unsere Methodik, aber
Insgesamt verstehen wir die
Nachhaltigkeit von Unternehmen, indem wir den Prozentsatz des
Umsatzes betrachten, der positiv oder negativ
auf die 17 SDGs ausgerichtet ist.
Für diejenigen unter Ihnen, die damit nicht vertraut sind,
sind die SDGs Rahmen  ork too
ähm, das sich mit mehreren Bereichen der
Nachhaltigkeit befasst, von Armut über die
Umwelt bis hin zu anderen Dingen wie
Demokratie, also ist es eine
Art allumfassender und ziemlich
komplexer Rahmen, der viele
Bereiche erfasst, die uns interessieren, also wir
als ich  Sehen Sie sich die Umsatzausrichtung der Unternehmen
auf jedes dieser verschiedenen
SDGs an, und
wir tun dies, indem wir die Auswirkungen verstehen, die
diese Produkte, die
Produkte und Dienstleistungen des Unternehmens auf jedes
der verschiedenen SDGs haben.
In diesem Fall habe ich Apple
als Beispiel herangezogen
und was wir  Auf der linken Seite sehen Sie
ein Diagramm, in dem jedes
Segment jedes der verschiedenen SDGs darstellt,
und
was wir sehen, ist, dass zum Beispiel bei einem
Produkt wie einem Smartphone, wenn ich
darauf klicke, die verschiedenen
SDGs angezeigt werden  stellen fest, dass es einen einfluss hat, also sehen
wir, dass smartphones einen positiven
einfluss auf die gesundheit (sdg3) oder
bildung (sdg4) haben, aber einen negativen
einfluss auf das sdg 12, bei dem es um
verantwortungsvollen konsum und produktion geht  Um
diese Auswirkungen zu verstehen und zu verstehen,
woher sie kommen, verwenden wir unsere
maschinellen Lernmodelle auf Millionen
von begutachteten akademischen Texten,
um diese Schlussfolgerungen über die Auswirkungen zu ziehen, ähm
aus
diesen Berechnungen, was wir am Ende erhalten,
ist im Grunde
ein Maß dafür, ob  ein positiv ist sehr
positiv oder ob unser produkt sehr
positiv oder sehr negativ ist und wir kombinieren
dies mit den
erträgen jedes einzelnen produkts, um für ein
unternehmen als ganzes zu verstehen, wie viel erlös
positiv oder negativ auf
jedes der verschiedenen sdgs ausgerichtet ist
um i  Ich denke, eines der Dinge, die
definitiv am interessantesten
an dem sind, was wir tun und wie wir es ausdrücken,
ist, dass
wir definitiv
alle positiven und negativen Aspekte betrachten
und berücksichtigen, dass
nicht alles sein wird  Schwarz oder
Weiß und
wie in den Beispielen mit meinen
Smartphones sehen wir, dass
es in einer
Reihe von Bereichen positiv beiträgt, aber es gibt einige
Arten  von negativen Ergebnissen, die sich auch
aus der Verwendung dieser Produkte ergeben, und
wir zielen darauf ab, all diese verschiedenen Nuancen darin zu erfassen,
wie wir die Auswirkungen von Unternehmen verstehen – eine
weitere sehr interessante Sache, die wir
erfassen und
die vielleicht etwas weniger mit der
Maschine zusammenhängt  Lernen, aber es
erlaubt uns definitiv, die Ergebnisse, die wir zusammengetragen haben, in den Kontext zu stellen
,
in
dem diese Unternehmen ihre Produkte verkaufen
, sodass
alle unsere Daten geografisch angepasst werden,
sodass wir in diesem Beispiel
hier sehen, dass 25 von Apples Einnahmen
positiv auf sdg4 und ausgerichtet sind  der durchgezogene
Balken genau die gepunktete Linie darüber
stellt die unbereinigten Ergebnisse dar.
Was wir also mit 25
des geografisch
bereinigten Umsatzes meinen, meinen wir, dass
wir berücksichtigen, wie viel relativer
Bedarf für diese Produkte
an dem Ort besteht, an dem Apple sie der
Reihe nach verkauft
um die Ergebnisse unserer
maschinellen Lernmodelle anzupassen, und wir
weisen Unternehmen grundsätzlich einen höheren positiven Einfluss
zu, wenn a  ihre
Produkte an Orten verkaufen, wo sie am
dringendsten benötigt werden,
und diejenigen, die Produkte verkaufen
, an denen weniger Bedarf besteht
, und umgekehrt, sowie
Unternehmen
mit negativen Auswirkungen,
ähm, ich denke, das fasst ein bisschen zusammen,
was wir anbieten  unsere kunden und äh wie unsere
daten aussehen ich weiß nicht ob jose
wahrscheinlich etwas hinzufügen möchte
ich füge nur einen schnellen sinn der
zahlen hinzu äh bevor ich es jose übergebe äh um
ein bisschen darüber zu reden  Die ai-Seite
der Dinge
ähm, wenn wir uns Unternehmen wie dieses ansehen,
einen unserer Konkurrenten, zum Beispiel
haben sie jetzt die Anzahl der Unternehmen erhöht,
die sie abdecken, aber normalerweise wird
sogar ein groß angelegter Betrieb in einem
großen Unternehmen,
äh, Datenunternehmen, abgedeckt  Irgendwo
zwischen dreitausend und zehntausend
Unternehmen, ähm, ich würde sagen, die engsten
Konkurrenten, die wir haben, die
in diesem Bereich tätig sind, ähm
[Musik],
es umfasst wahrscheinlich etwa 3.500 Unternehmen
, das ist ein Projekt in den Niederlanden,
wir c  über 45.000 Unternehmen, das ist also
jede Liste, jedes Unternehmen, das
an irgendeiner Börse der Welt notiert ist, äh,
das ist bereits eine beträchtliche Anzahl von
Unternehmen, die wir als nächstes abdecken,
nur um ein paar weitere Zahlen darum
herum zu setzen,
ähm
für jedes Unternehmen, das wir haben  fünfjährige
Geschichte, so dass alle unsere
Datenpunkte für jedes Unternehmen mit fünf multipliziert werden. Wir
haben alle positiven und negativen Prozentsätze der SDGs,
und wir tun dies als
Dollarwert, und wir haben die Ergebnisse, die Sie
unten rechts sehen  Der Bildschirm ist
dort auch, also haben wir für jedes Unternehmen
etwa 750 Datenpunkte.
Wenn Sie also an einen Datensatz denken, der
750 Datenpunkte für 45.000 Unternehmen und
etwa 12.000 Produkte und Dienstleistungen umfasst
, ist das ein sehr großer, äh, großer
Datensatz  Sie wissen, wir haben diesen
äh Datensatz produziert mit einem wirklich
kleinen Team, wir haben das Team
vergrößert, jetzt sind wir nur noch ein Dutzend Leute, also
ähm, und das soll Ihnen ein Gefühl dafür geben,
wie viel Hebelwirkung es hat
summen  ein Input und die Menge an Maschinenoutput
ist enorm und das ist eines der
Dinge, die wirklich wichtig sind, wenn
wir KI so verwenden, wie wir es tun, aber das ist,
um Ihnen einige Zahlen zu geben, die ich an
Jose weitergeben werde, wenn es welche gibt  Bestimmte
Dinge, von denen Sie denken, dass sie
für die Klasse interessant wären, wie wir
die KI machen, die interessant wären, also
wie ich sagte, ähm, so offensichtlich ist
die Frage hier, wie wir
das maschinelle Lernen tatsächlich nutzen, um
dies zu erreichen  Punkt
und hier, wie wenn wir ein wirklich
komplexes System aus verschiedenen Modellen des maschinellen
Lernens haben, aber
von einem eher theoretischen Standpunkt aus
so, dass das, was wir tatsächlich mit dem
maschinellen Lernen tun, nicht wirklich
vorhersagt,
was das Unternehmen tut,
sondern was  Wir verwenden maschinelles
Lernen in großem Maßstab, um das Wissen zu identifizieren und zu
aggregieren, das
in unserem Fall bereits in
akademischen Veröffentlichungen vorhanden ist, sodass wir über einen Pool
von etwa 120 Millionen akademischen
Publikationen verfügen
Eine Reihe von Artikeln sind wie ein Analyst,
wie sogar
ein Haufen Analysten oder wie Millionen von
Analysten, wie Patrick sagte,
was wirklich schwer zu lesen und zu
verstehen wäre, und selbst wenn sie es lesen
und verstehen könnten, wie würden Sie die
Konsistenz zwischen den Analysten wahren?  Wie können
Sie sicher sein, dass ein
Analyst nicht seine eigenen Vorurteile einbringt und ein
anderer Analyst nicht einige Teile überspringt,
also ist die Idee okay, wie gehen wir
von diesen 120 Millionen Artikeln aus
und wie identifizieren wir
jede einzelne
Instanz eines Unternehmens?
produkt oder aktion und ein nachhaltigkeitsthema
in unserem fall haben wir die sdgs definiert,
also konzentrieren wir uns darauf, was die
auswirkungen dieser produkte sind, die wir
hier sehen, also zum beispiel im fall von apple
smartphones wie musik- und video-
streaming tragbare geräte auf die
verschiedenen themen  dass wir in diesem
Fall nachhaltige Entwicklungsziele
haben, also fragen wir das
maschinelle Lernen, damit maschinelles Lernen
wie wir
alle alle finden werden  Die Artikel, die sagen, dass Smartphones in Ordnung sind,
haben entweder
positive oder negative Auswirkungen, sodass
Smartphones gut für die
Gesundheit sein können, da sie es den Menschen ermöglichen,
Informationen auszutauschen
, wie Sie möchten, wie Sie schneller einen Krankenwagen rufen
können
und Zugang zu Informationen erhalten über
Gesundheit,
also können Smartphones gut sein wie SDG3
Gesundheit, aber gleichzeitig
produzieren Smartphones eine Menge Abfall, also stellt sich die Frage,
wie wir all diese Informationen
zusammenbringen und wie wir sie dann aggregieren,
damit wir am Ende
einen einzigen Wert
für jede haben  Unternehmen gegen jede SDG und
hier findet unser maschinelles Lernen
statt, also kann
ich natürlich gerne in
den wirklich detaillierten Teil
des maschinellen Lernens einsteigen, aber es war so, als wäre es
vielleicht interessanter, welche Art
von und welche Modelle wir verwenden  wie mehr
High-Level und was wir so verwenden, ist das,
was es Transformer-basierte
Modelle nennt, die eines der neuesten und
Fortschritte im maschinellen Lernen sind, also wahrscheinlich
Sie  Ich habe alle davon gehört, wie all diese wie
gpd3 und all diese berühmten Models und jetzt
wie ähm sind in der Nähe, für die sie verwendet werden,
wie zum Beispiel neulich habe
ich einen interessanten Artikel gelesen, wie sie
eines dieser Models interviewt haben und
es war ziemlich  Es ist interessant, wie ähnlich
sie auf Sie reagieren können, aber
was maschinelles Lernen tatsächlich tut,
ist
, Muster in den Daten zu identifizieren, damit sie
nicht so tun, als würden
sie nicht wirklich denken, dass maschinelles
Lernen im Moment nicht wirklich denkt,
also tun wir es nicht  Wir haben wie eine allgemeine KI, aber
was wir haben, ist ein System, das wirklich
gut darin ist, konsistent zu sein und
Muster zu erkennen, das heißt, es ist ein
System, das wirklich gut darin ist, zu identifizieren,
welche Artikel sagen, dass Smartphones
gut für die Gesundheit sind, und welche Artikel sagen,
dass Smartphones es sind  gut für sind
zum Beispiel schlecht für den Klimawandel.
Sobald wir das haben und das alles aggregieren
, kommen wir zu dem Teil, dass
es nicht so viel maschinelles Lernen ist, aber
wir haben ein System, das etwa wie ein Gra ist  Ph-
Netzwerk, wo wir jedes einzelne
Unternehmen mit Produkten zu all diesen wie
Tausenden von verschiedenen Auswirkungen verbinden, und dann bringen
wir es auf einen einzigen Wert
pro Unternehmen und SDG, was
für unsere Investoren wirklich hilfreich ist, und ich werde
hier aufhören, ich don  Ich weiß nicht, ob es
irgendwelche Fragen zu all dem gibt,
aber für uns ist es eine Art einfache
Sache, weil wir jeden
Tag damit arbeiten, aber es ist, als gäbe es Tausende von
Fragen, die herumgestellt werden könnten